So I was thinking the other day
about
numbers.
You know,
there are mathematicians who think
that there isn't anything more real,
the numbers.
And that's an interesting proposition.
I mean it's obviously the case that
once you invent or discover numbers that
that confers on you a tremendous power.
Who knows the limits of that power and
the claim that numbers are more real than
anything else is predicated in part on
the fact that when you discover the marine
vent them and start to utilize them,
that your ability to operate
in the world expands immensely.
And,
and so that's one of the ways of judging
whether or not something is real is
whether or not when you use it,
that facilitates your means
of operating in the world.
Interestingly,
numbers are abstractions.
And so that raises another question,
which is,
well,
what's more real?
The thing that's being abstracted
from or the abstractions.
And again,
that's not obvious.
Um,
and maybe the question of
more real isn't Germane.
Maybe it's a question of equal reality,
but it's not obvious that abstractions
aren't real and you can make a damn
strong case that they're
more real than anything else.
And so then you might ask yourself,
well then what are the
most real abstractions?
And so that's what I'm going
to start to talk about tonight.
I'm going to talk about it in
relationship to as many rules as I can
layout simultaneously.
I'll go through the rules first.
So rule one is stand up straight with
your shoulders back and rule two is treat
yourself like you're someone
responsible for helping a number three,
which is very tightly
associated with number two.
They're sort of variations on a theme is
make friends with those people who want
the best for you.
And by the way,
these last two rules aren't injunctions
designed to make your life easier.
They're actually injunctions designed
to make your life more difficult.
Um,
Kierkegaard said at one
point that his role in life,
given that everything was proceeding to
become easier and easier in all possible
ways,
that there would come a time when
people would cry out for difficulty.
And so that's partly how he
envisioned his role in the world.
Interestingly enough,
as a universal benefactor of mankind who
had strived to do nothing other than to
make life more difficult for everyone.
Right?
And so rule two and three are like that
because treat yourself as if you're
someone responsible for helping isn't
the same as be nice to yourself.
It's not that.
And to associate with people who want
the best for you means that they get to
demand the best from you.
And that's also not an easy thing.
Rule four is compare yourself to who you
were yesterday and not to someone else
is today.
And that's an injunction about envy,
right?
It's easy.
You need people who you need things that
are above you because you need to do
something worthwhile with your life.
You need something to aim at.
But one of the consequences of that is
that you can become envious of people
that you believe have attained more
in a deserved or undeserved manner.
And that can make you better.
And so it's much better to
compare yourself to yourself
and to use yourself as
the target for improvement.
And comparison.
Rule five is don't let your children do
anything that makes you dislike them.
And the rule of thumb there
is if you dislike them,
then other people will and it's a bad
idea to allow your children to act in a
way that makes other children
dislike them or adults dislike them,
given that they're going to have to deal
with children and they're going to have
to deal with adults.
So your primary responsibility as a
parent is to help your child learn how to
behave so that the social world opens
up its arms to them and welcomes them at
every level and you've done your job.
If you can manage that,
and it's not a simple thing to do,
rural six is put your house in perfect
order before you criticize the world and
that's not take no action for others
until you have your act together.
That isn't what the rule means.
It means that bind your ambition with
humility and work on what's right in front
of you that you will suffer for if you
get wrong before you engage in the large
scale transformation of other people.
Rule seven is do what is meaningful
and not what is expedient.
And I would say in some sense,
in some sense,
that's the core ethos of the book,
not exactly because rule eight,
which is tell the truth or at least don't
lie as a necessary conjunction to that
are unnecessary additional element.
Because I don't think that you can pursue
what is meaningful without telling the
truth.
And the reason for that is if you don't
tell the truth or let's say if you lie,
which is an easier way to think about it,
you corrupt the mechanisms,
the instinctual mechanisms that that
that manifest themselves as meaning and
then you can't trust them.
And that's a very bad idea.
So the fundamental reason to not
lie is because you corrupt your own
perceptions.
If you lie and when you
corrupt your own perceptions,
then you can't rely on yourself.
And if you can't rely on yourself,
then well,
good luck to you because what are you
going to rely on in the absence of your
own judgment?
Here,
you've got nothing.
If you,
if you lose that rule,
rule eight
is,
as I said,
tell the truth or don't,
or at least don't lie.
Rule nine,
assume that the person that you're
listening to know something you don't.
And that's not so much a mark
of respect for the person,
although it is that it's a
mark of recognition of your
own unbearable ignorance.
You know,
one of the things you have to do in
life is decide whether you're more,
you have to make friends more with,
let me see,
let me just,
let me rephrase that properly.
You have to decide what's more important,
what you know or what you don't know.
First of all,
there's a lot of what you don't know.
And so if you make friends with that,
if you decide that's important,
then well that's a good thing because
you're going to be surrounded by what you
don't know your entire life.
And so if you're appreciative of that,
then that's going to make
things go better for you.
But,
but the other element of that is,
well,
why should you be appreciative of what
you don't know and answer to that is,
well,
you shouldn't.
If you're life is absolutely perfect in
every way you have exactly what you need
and want.
You've put everything in order around you,
then what you know is sufficient.
But if you believe that things could
still be put right around you in your own
personal life and with regard to the
effect that you have another people,
then obviously what you don't yet know
is more important than what you do know.
And you should be paying attention to
find out what you don't know at every
possible moment.
And if you're fortunate when you have
a conversation with someone and you're
actually interested in what they say,
then even if they're not
very good at communicating,
even if they're awkward or even if
they display a certain amount of enmity
towards you,
there's always the possibility that
they might tell you something you don't
know,
in which case you can walk away from the
conversation less ignorant and corrupt.
Then you were when you
started the conversation.
And if your life isn't everything that
you would like it to be than being
slightly less ignorant and corrupt is
probably a good thing and so rule 10 is be
precise in your speech and that's,
that's an observation.
I would say that that's a variant
of a new testament injunction,
which is,
or maybe a description of the nature of
the world which is knock and the door
will open and ask and you will receive,
which is a very strange theory let's say,
but which I would say is far more in
accordance with what we know about the
psychology of perception,
let's say.
Then you might imagine
because it is the case that
okay,
you don't get what you don't aim at.
You might get what you do a mat and
your aim might get better as you aim as
well,
which is something to consider.
Yeah.
If you specify the nature of the,
actually,
if you specify the nature of the being
that you want to bring into being,
then you radically increase the
probability that that's what will occur.
And of course you all know that because
you regard yourself at least to some
degree as active creative agents,
right?
Your fundamental attitude towards yourself
at at least in the manner that you
act towards yourself is that you wake up
in the morning and you have a landscape
of possibilities that lay themselves
open to you and you make choices between
those possibilities and determined in
consequence how the world is going to
manifest itself.
So you confront a field of potential.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
And through your choices you determine
which elements of that potential are
going to concretize them selves into
the real world and you are very unhappy
with yourself.
If you don't do that properly and
you're very unhappy with other people.
If they don't do that properly and you're
very unhappy with other people if they
don't treat you like that's what you're
like because part of what you demand
from people let's say in terms of sheer
civility is that they act towards you is
if you're the locus of voluntary choice
in a world of potential and you are
braid each other for that as well.
If you have children and parents,
your parents will say to you,
if you're fortunate you're not
living up to your potential,
which is actually a compliment in a sense.
Even though it's also a judgment and
the compliment is I know perfectly well
that you could be more than you are and
you'll hang your head if you have any
sense.
And you'll think like you
think in relationship to
your own conscience that yes
I have a lot of potential that I'm
not fully realizing and that actually
constitutes a transgression
against the good and I don't,
I don't think I've ever met anyone
who doesn't believe that if you,
if you have a reasonable
conversation with them,
it just seems self evident.
I mean maybe now and then you meet someone
who's narcissistically self satisfied
but then they're narcissistic
and that's not good.
That as a,
as a medium to long term strategy,
that's a catastrophe
that ends in disaster.
You know,
it's a short term,
it protects people,
but long term it's,
it's not good in the least.
And of course other people
know to appreciate it as well.
Rule 11 is don't bother children when
they're skateboarding and that's actually
a discussion of courage,
of encouragement more,
more specifically because I've,
I've been trying to
understand for example,
what role parents play in the lives of
their children and I would say this is a
role that,
that that is a fundamental importance
as well as attempting to guide your
children so that they act in a socially
desirable manner so that the world opens
itself up to them.
You also want to encourage them,
which is not the same as sheltering them.
It's not the same at all.
And to encourage someone
is to say something like,
or to act out something like,
look,
kid,
as you meet,
the world's already difficult because the
world isn't easy for children any more
than,
it's easy for adults that
the difficulties are,
they're not the same,
their child's size difficulties,
but there are still difficulties.
The world is a very hard place and it's
a bitter place in many ways and it's not
only a hard and bitter place.
It's also touched with betrayal and
malevolence and that's the fundamental
bottom line,
but there's something in you that is
capable of taking that full on and
transcending it and that's encouragement.
You say,
well,
as difficult as things are Europe to
the challenge and to interfere with
children when they're skateboarding,
for example,
when they're doing,
let's say in advisably dangerous things,
which kids of course do,
if they're skateboarding,
to interfere with that is to interfere
with the child's willingness to
voluntarily expose themselves to the
risks that they need to expose themselves
to in order to develop this sort of
competence that allows them to thrive in a
world they cannot be sheltered from.
And so to interfere with children when
they're taking necessary risks is not
love or empathy,
but cowardice on the part of parents
and it's deeply damaging to children.
And I can tell you as a
clinical psychologist,
I've never had a client come to
my office in all the hundreds in,
in all of the hundreds of encounters
I've had with people in my office,
I've never had a client say my
parents made me two independent,
right?
That hasn't happened once.
Right now my parents made me too dependent
or I conspired with my parents to
perpetuate my dependence.
That happened all the time.
So there's a rule of thumb,
which I think is a good one,
which I believe is often
applied to nursing homes by
people who work in nursing
homes,
which is of course a very difficult job.
And the rule is do not do anything
for anyone they can do for themselves.
And the reason for that is
that it's a form of theft,
right?
You don't,
first of all,
you,
if you do something for someone and
it facilitates their movement forward,
then they moved forward
because you help them,
which is something I was very
careful about as a therapist.
I don't want to give my
clients advice first.
It might fail,
in which case they are
going to pay for my advice.
And second,
if it succeeds,
then I get to be the successful one.
And I don't want to steal
the success from my clients.
That's a bad idea.
I want to help them figure out what it
is that they should aim at and then help
plot out a strategy for attaining that.
And,
but I,
I,
I want to ensure that it's their destiny,
not something I'm imposing.
And of course the imposition of that
sort of thing is the hallmark of a bad,
I would say therapeutic relationship,
but also a bad relationship period.
Right?
So one of the things you want
to do with your partners,
your spouse,
your say,
your husband or wife and
also with your children,
is to listen to them so that you can
figure out what their problems are and
figure out with them because they're
going to figure that out by communicating
and then perhaps aid them in
the development of a strategy.
But you have to ensure very carefully
that you're not imposing your own
structure in a manner that's going to
steal from them what's rightfully theirs.
So well,
so rule 11 is an injunction to
courage as the fundamental cause.
You could say,
well,
what's the antidote to
the catastrophe of life?
And one answer might be safety.
It's like,
well,
you know,
look,
everyone's sensible enough to know that
a certain amount of provision for safety
is,
is worthwhile.
You should probably wear your seat belts
when you're driving around in your car
because why take foolhardy risks.
But given that there
is no security in life,
in the final analysis,
then encouragement is a much
better medication than sheltering.
And so,
and that,
that's,
that's I think in keeping with the idea
that what life is essentially is not a
place to attain happiness or
even to aim for happiness,
even though you should be grateful
if someone comes along now and then,
but a call to something like adventure.
And I think that's the proper
way of conceptualizing it.
Certainly if you go watch a story,
a movie,
you read a book,
something like that.
If you encounter a
narrative that's gripping,
whether it's a romance or
a classic adventure story,
then the element of it that's
gripping is the adventure.
And so to portray life is
an adventure in romance and,
and in the world is the
proper way to portray it.
And the way that you
facilitate the adventure
is through encouragement.
I had a client once,
I really liked him.
He was a good guy.
He's smart guy,
good looking young guy,
had everything going for him.
You know,
he's good musician.
He was a talented athlete.
Um,
yeah,
but he hadn't been encouraged.
I wouldn't say,
yeah.
He told me about his
relationship with his girlfriend.
He said,
Huh?
His girlfriend wanted to go
biking around southern Ontario.
She was about 19 or 20 and he thought
he might join her and when she went and
talked to her parents,
they made every provision possible to
help her prepare for the journey to make
sure her bike was in good shape,
to make sure she had the right
equipment to help her plot out a route.
And when he went and
talked to his parents,
all they did was worried that he was
going to get hurt and like he might get
hurt because
yeah,
people get hurt,
but
okay.
They didn't understand that they were
choosing between the hurt that he might
encounter by going out in the
world and having an adventure,
let's say with his girlfriend or the hurt
that he would encounter by staying at
home,
cowering in his basement under the
protection of his over loving parents.
Well,
his girlfriend ventured
bravely into the world.
You think,
well,
which of those two things is
most likely to be damaging?
And their answer to that is,
well,
his parents wouldn't
worry as much as if he,
if he was in the basement and that's
the wrong worry even because they should
worry more,
not less.
So in rural 12 his pedicab,
when you encounter one
on the street and it's
oddly enough,
a meditation on fragility,
it's a discussion of what you do when
you don't know what to do and that's
really when things have
gone badly for you.
When you face a terrible tragedy in your
own personal life or in your familiar
life or perhaps even in
the life of your community,
when things come crowding
in and you too quickly,
in the case of a death in the family or
a terrible illness or the collapse of a
dream or any of the things that can flip
your world upside down is how do you
cope with that?
And that chapter contains discussion
of the necessity of narrowing your
timeframe.
You know,
because sometimes the right way to
look at the world is across years and
sometimes it's across months.
And when things are more out of control,
perhaps it's across days.
And when things are really,
when you're really up against the wall,
it's across hours or even minutes.
And during those minutes
then you concentrate on
doing as well as you can with
what's right in front of
you for the longest unit of
time that you can tolerate,
conceptualize it.
Maybe that's what you do
at someone's deathbed.
And while you're doing that
and suffering away madly,
then you also take the time to
appreciate everything you can.
That manifests itself,
that allows itself to be appreciated.
And so that's the metaphor of the cat,
I suppose.
And so that's the 12 rules.
And I'll return to rule one,
which is stand up straight
with your shoulders back.
And I'm going to use it as a platform
for laying out the abstractions that I
talked to at the beginning of the lecture.
So.